ya know welcome to this video playing
DWG 6 from the UK so hmm c-45 p3 ok why
not why not the id-5 has considered to
be good here I mean equal let's do it
hmm he's spinning me that's not nice so
how do you play that c6 is hanging but
shifted to is a bit of a small move but
probably not bad also I have 90 before
now as a threat somewhat of a threat oh
now thats its ambitious ok if I go f5 he
probably he has Bishop c4 ok
just have to keep it simple him check
okay now i have e 495 this should be
rather nice i should i should check the
capture though this is not not bad
either I guess because I have an
immediate f for ya f form where does he
go with the king I cannot believe in
Long castles and I'm threatening to take
and play Queen h4 and short cancelling
know that that gets killed with f3 I
guess
hmm it's awkward yeah I wanted to go 95
initially but yeah probably has to do
this some move like this okay m route
ticks or what probably Wow mf3 yeah I
think so I just double arm it's there
let's get this double and then go from
there III is also now a move bishops is
six Bishop to b5 is also also possible
you
okay really not sure about all this
rookie one III it's very very tactical
position
III I Queenie two or something or quindi
one hmm but I ever gave to win in almost
all cases or in all cases i don't know
let's play it I'm going to play it
anyway so I might as well just do it
[Music]
it's not like I'm winning or anything
it's really not um we should be three
maybe set a move Q intakes you have to
check good work if I take I group to
that doesn't win 53 I'm not sure my neck
my time is ticking okay can i play it
I'll play it I at least take stinks
if I take F to cam seems to work Queen
f3 rook takes bishop tanks I can just
take f1 which is not directly winning
but three Queen takes looks like the
movie has to play and have no more this
one okay okay Queenie three looks yeah
time were they don't have a win here
directly i mean at least i didn't see
one my king position is also not that
grade
check and check on you for a rookie to
now look into now it's not not so nice
snow queen bee three I probably have to
play rookie to looks totally normal
though not sure what what else he is
considering
[Music]
and we had connection problem check
check check check check white forfeits
on time it's pretty awkward to defend
against Queen such a position Puma very
very tricky so yeah this must be must be
pretty good at this point therefore that
was the best move yeah III came into
consideration but just just felt natural
and good g3 look at three castles yeah
maybe I should have played the immediate
III but hard to believe that this should
be bad okay be sheriff I've just win
that stance that's good at least and
then here Oh Bishop before Wow very nice
move okay so then
not sure that I understand it so like
this this this this is the thing it's
very nice very aesthetic and this moon
that Queen takes Queen takes I didn't
really see anything great like this this
this and now I wasn't really sure I mean
of course I can take this I wasn't sure
about at all because this is a real self
pin and f3 actually just do some work
m-f three works yeah I would have sorry
I would have probably taken here and
then play this position which is very
tricky I mean black might be a lot
better but maybe yeah he had a couple of
things going on the rook Hanks and then
screen to a2 nice but it's it's very
difficult to play with no time okay this
is yeah this is better for black button
it's so difficult I was thinking okay to
hear I would have gone here and seems it
doesn't have anything director no well
tough game thanks for watching